hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mine your decisions
a chinese university entrance exam maths
question leaves us teachers stumped
that's according to the south china
morning post
a u.s teacher tried to solve a problem
from this year's gao cow a chinese
college entrance exam known for its
difficulty
to quote from the article posts about
the video have been viewed 140 million
times on the micro blogging site weibo
and the video has been picked up by
other chinese news media
i was very interested in this problem
but there was an issue
the problem was written in chinese and
at first i could not find an english
translation
i posted the problem to twitter and i
owe a huge thanks to two people who
kindly translated the problem for me so
that i could share it to you in this
video
by the way you can also follow me on
twitter at preshtalwalker
so here's the problem
the domain of f of x is all real numbers
and satisfies f of x plus one is equal
to two times f of x
for x in the interval zero to one
not including zero but including one
f of x is equal to x times the quantity
x minus one
for values where x goes from negative
infinity to m inclusive
f of x is greater than or equal to
negative eight over nine
what is the value of m
is it nine fourths
seven over three
five over two or eight over three
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so this is a very intimidating problem
let's break it down step by step and get
a real understanding of what the
question is asking
so we'll start out with the most
concrete information
for x in the interval 0 to 1 not
including 0 but including 1 f of x is
equal to x times the quantity x minus 1.
let's make a plot of this function
we'll go from 0 to 1 and let's graph
what this function will look like
well x times the quantity x minus 1 will
be a parabola
and it's going to go between the points
0 0 and 1 0. now technically 0 is not
included in this interval but
essentially the graph is going to go
from 0 0 to 1 0
and we're just going to get a sketch of
what this graph looks like so that we
can get a better understanding of the
question
now the minimum value of this parabola
is going to be right in the middle and
it's going to be an f of 0.5 which is
equal to negative 0.25
so let's just sketch what this function
looks like
i'm also going to put the function right
here so that we can keep track of the
function as we graph the other intervals
now let's try and graph this function in
other intervals
we know that f of x plus 1 is equal to 2
times f of x
now we can evaluate a couple of points
and we're quickly going to deduce that
the graph in the next interval 1 to 2
will be twice the height of the graph in
0 to 1.
we're going to shift over this parabola
and we're going to multiply it by 2.
so this graph is going to look something
like this and this is because of the
property that f of x 1 is equal to 2
times f of x
now when we shift a function over the
variable x is going to be back to x
minus 1.
so this parabola is going to have a
graph of 2 because it's twice as tall
and this can be multiplied by the
quantity x minus 1 multiplied by the
quantity x minus 2.
so let's continue graphing this in the
next interval it's going to be twice the
height of the graph in the interval from
1 to 2 and shift it over
so it's going to look something like
this so this parabola will have an
equation 4 times the quantity x minus 2
times the quantity x minus 3.
we can also shift this graph to the left
it's going to be half the height so in
this interval negative one to zero it's
going to be half the height and in this
interval negative two to negative one
it's gonna be half the height
and the pattern continues
so looking at this graph we want f of x
to be greater than or equal to negative
eight over nine
so let's put negative 8 over 9 as a line
in this graph let's do y is equal to
negative 8 over 9.
now you'll see in the third interval
from 2 to 3 it's going to intersect
so at some point f of x is gonna be less
than negative eight over nine
and we want to look for the points where
f of x is greater than or equal to
negative eight over nine
so we're looking for this value m
in which
f of x is always greater than or equal
to negative 8 over 9. we want to solve
where this parabolas equation is equal
to negative 8 over 9 and we solve for
the smallest value
so let's go ahead and solve this algebra
problem
but there's a little trick you might
actually guess some of the factors
notice that four times one-third times
negative two-thirds is equal to negative
eight over nine
and four times two-thirds times negative
one-third is also equal to negative
eight over nine
you quickly see the first equation x
would be equal to seven thirds and the
second equation x is equal to eight over
three
we want the smallest x value so we just
take x is equal to seven over three
but if you didn't see that trick you can
go ahead and solve it like you would
solve a standard quadratic equation we
go ahead and factor we end up with two
results and we want the smallest x value
so now
f of x will be greater than or equal to
negative eight over nine
if x is less than or equal to seven over
three so going back to the question we
want to know what is the value of m
and in our answer choices it's going to
be answer choice b
seven over three
and that's the answer to this very
challenging problem and it took me quite
a while to solve too
but i think it's a pretty interesting
problem
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
[Music]